I winter welcome to this video as some
chaos is some chaos so some we yep and
g6 currently testing this line so 93
okay don't see that so often them in
them in the way that wow what is that
even possible okay okay okay just just a
moment that let's not get too hasty but
I think I can just take it huh
so so 9070 plays Bishop g5 that that's
not so great I can go be five
can also play c6 first and yeah okay get
this night to FY maybe this is the way
to start it should be good no matter
what you base if you just gave me a poem
for for nothing but Queen 85 why didn't
that the Queen a five I could have done
that one move earlier clock and it's
still good because h4 didn't change the
situation all that much Oh could done
that the move before yeah that's a big
problem now winning winning everything
here well that's a big career of the
deep on e5 took default proxy 32 p 2 and
then wind tons of material in the
process white resigns or the short game
yeah okay maybe yeah it can still be
kind of useful the mess a tell something
about the opening a little bit so this
is an interesting line a 67 g6 I have
tried to move g6 in some games but I
dislike discontinuation where we should
be seven this kind of thing happens and
this is a position I simply don't enjoy
playing with black it's not all that
terrible but it's not really my cup of
tea you can do this also but after nine
txt for while it's also a little bit a
little bit better here in the MU g6
looks kind of useless him and you don't
have a really great move now if
something like a six white is happily
returning and will I mean something like
this let's
it's not super terrible for blackboard
white of course is a bit better he's got
more space for no particular drawback so
I'll go 86 first and jen g6 the
difference is if they go d for now and
play Bishop g5 that here this position
night takes is a little bit more
interesting because now if he goes nine
txt for I actually can play beehive this
is a difference and it makes them it is
quite substantial an interesting point
is that after nine c6 black actually can
take with the pawn and this leads to a
pretty fascinating position by Queen
takes King takes we should PNC five you
see that this is so also what the engine
gives it's something that I recently
found while looking through some lines
that this is actually kind of
interesting and note that if wife takes
ruka age he's not in good shape his
bishop is basically trapped in something
like this perhaps the bishop so he went
like this 93 now Bishop g7 it's a little
bit difficult now to give White's play
nem young any aggressive Flay I am
deform it should normally white ghost
castles or place III and this is leading
to positions like that where I think
white probably has a slight advantage as
your often has in the way but it is
nothing special in particular it's a
little bit offbeat so interesting to
play once in a while yeah d 4 I don't
think this works simply taking with the
night I mean again this in particular
doesn't work yeah I can't go create five
already it was just add up I don't know
what blind spot call it what you want i
can win here already with this the same
as in the game he probably should go
back to eat
but this is just material down I mean
there's no compensation NT Queen a five
already was a was winning as it was on
the game key a yes no I'm threatening to
take this was check and you cannot take
and that's just a move I to lose a son
yeah peas the rook can just yeah choose
want to want to basically give up ok
guys thanks for watching